We considered for a long time,
a world of certain day, um,
oops,
something's okay.
Consider it a world of certainty where
we assumed we could foresee the future
perfectly and we still managed to
figure out fairly interesting things,
but the world is much more complicated
that than that it's a world of
uncertainty. And in a
world of uncertainty, uh,
economics is, comes into its own as
a f I think, fascinating subject.
So I spend a little time reviewing some
mathematics for you last time that many
of you already knew.
So I'm going to take that for granted
going forward and just start over this
time from an economic perspective
instead of a mathematical perspective.
So suppose today that we assume that
you could buy a stock today who's price
tomorrow could be a 104 or 98 with 50,
50 probabilities. And we assume that
everybody knew the probabilities.
Okay,
no probabilities and maximize
expected. Hey, uh,
next period.
Okay, well, uh, plus, uh,
paying off this period
if we assumed,
and we're going to drop this assumption,
but I might keep it for a little while
if we assume that all people cared about
was the expected payoff next period.
And of course they care about
their pay off this period,
what would the value of
this stock have to be? Well,
under the simple rule for how people act,
you'd take a half times 104
plus a half times 98. Yeah.
And that would give you, uh,
what would that give you?
Give you a 101.
Okay.
Because this is plus four times a half
is plus two minus one minus two times a
half, which is minus one. So it's
plus one. So that'll give you 101.
So you would say that the price of
the stock today would have to be 101.
Now we could slightly refine this utility
function and see people maximize the
discounted
expected payoff next period.
Plus the payoff this period.
And if the discount
is Wa is a a hundred over 101 okay,
then we're going to have to multiply this
by a hundred over 101 and we'll get a
price of 100 okay,
so that's the basic first step.
We can incorporate uncertainty by assuming
people replace the uncertain outcomes
with certain outcomes in their head.
And then discount,
just like we've seen before,
of course before we had utility functions,
but I'm not going to do that quite yet.
I'm just going to say suppose
that we just did that. All right.
That would give us a theory of people
manage their manage uncertainty in react
to uncertainty and how they
set the prices. All right,
so what's the expected uh,
expectation theory of pricing.
Now, before we complicate the theory, I
want to just take this literally as true,
true and make some inferences from it.
Well,
the first in France you can make,
is that right?
MMM.
Today's price.
Today's price would then be the
ex the discounted expectation
of tomorrow's price.
Okay.
That's just repeating the same thing.
But what's an implication of that and
implication of that is if you didn't know
tomorrow's price?
No,
the expectation of tomorrow's price,
you could guess today's price.
Okay,
it's, I'm writing out this trivial fuck
because it's such an important idea.
Once you have a theory
of how price is formed,
you can always go backwards and as the
naive uninformed member of a society,
you can learn instead of about
learning about the stocks,
you can learn all you need to learn.
Perhaps by looking at the price,
you may be interested in what the expected
value of the stock is. Next period.
To do that in a serious way,
you'd have to study the firm's study,
the product study, the new inventions.
It was trying to learn new technologies.
It was trying to adopt, get some
idea of the quality of the manager.
You'd have to do a million
things to figure that out,
but if you just look at the price today,
maybe that's going to give
you a good expectation,
a good idea of what the expected
value of the firm is next period. So,
and that's another way that also
implies you can test the theory.
You know,
is it true that typically today's
price is a good forecast of the price
tomorrow,
the expected price tomorrow?
Obviously you can't just
look at one instance because
you would just be looking,
if things went up,
you'd be just looking at the 104 and a
hundred wouldn't be a good guess of 104.
But if you did this the next day and
things were independent on the second day
of the first day, you'd have a new
price, a hundred for the next day.
And you could see whether the
price went up or down or not.
And by doing this a thousand
times or 100,000 times,
you'd get a good idea if on average,
today's price was a pretty good
predictor of tomorrow's price.
Okay. So here's the,
um,
so I did that experiment and here it is,
right?
Uh, why is this all small? Okay,
so from 1980 I didn't do this.
Someone at my,
I got someone this morning
to do this at my hedge fund.
So what did he do? He said, um,
suppose you had a dollar to put in each
day starting in 1980 you could cheat,
keep track of uh,
how many dollars.
So you got $100 you can,
so it's $100 you have
$100 to invest each day.
MMM.
Starting January 1st,
1980 you put it into the s and p 500.
So you put it equally into all stocks,
the 500 biggest stocks,
and you'll see what the total price
of those 500 stocks is the next day.
And you subtract the original price and
that gives you your return on the first
day percent return on the first day.
For example,
it was 101 seems like
it went up a little bit.
You'd have a 1% you'd have made a dollar
in the first day. Then I told the guy,
or he decided himself,
put $100 in the second day in the s and
p 500 and see what happened to that the
next day.
Maybe it went up $3 the second day.
So your total after two days
would be $4 not your total return.
Well, that's how he's written
it. It's just the, you know,
the first day the stock
went up by a dollar,
the hundred dollars went up by a dollar.
The second day went up by $3
so all together went up by $4.
So the hypothesis is that today's price
is a good forecast of tomorrow's price.
So if you're averaging the pluses
and minuses over many days,
so there are 250 days for 30 years here,
that's a lot of days you're averaging.
So,
and you just see,
and this is the cumulative total
of what would have happened to you.
Okay. So, um,
well
that hundred dollars, if he did that
experiment, you know, 7,000 times,
30 times 250,
30 Times,
250th 7,500 times,
you would have ended up
with 350 or $400 by the end.
Okay. So does that contradict or, um,
confirm the hypothesis that we've just
made the today's price a good forecast of
the expectation of tomorrow's price?
What would you say?
Okay. Well, so that's a subtle answer.
So there are two things that I expected
you to say. That one being the second,
and I'm very important one. Um, you know,
it looks like $100 became $250,
you know,
300 $400 but that was over 30 years.
So what was the game per year,
you know,
7,500 days and you got a return of 250%
so you have to divide 250 by 7,500 and
you get some incredibly low number.
I forgot what it was,
but it was something like 0.004,
7% something like that.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you're making,
so this is percent I've
already divided by,
um, I've already divided by a
hundred to turn it into percentages.
So you make a tiny return,
you know,
on $100 you might go up on
average the next day to a hundred,
you know, and, and a half
dollars. Okay. But that's making
it, you know, and, and uh,
but at this 0.04, 7%. So
$1 would be, you know,
1% but this is, you know,
it would be a one here,
but we're not a lot of
decimal places there.
So you're dividing 250 by 7,500 maybe
I've got one decimal to money there.
So this is a tiny number.
So in fact,
today's price is a pretty good
estimate of tomorrow's price. You know,
you have $100 and maybe it'll turn
in on average two a hundred uh,
0.4, $7 tomorrow. Okay, so, you know,
compare it to knowing nothing.
If you asked yourself what's the average
value of this stock tomorrow, you don't,
no one's telling you it's
normalized at a hundred.
It could be 500 it could be 23 it could
be 75 who knows what the average of
these stocks are.
The S and p 500 is,
is mixing stocks that are worth three
with stocks that are worth 500 per share
with stocks that are worth 75 per share.
And it turns out that it's
such an accurate predictor
that you only are off by a
fraction of 1% on average each day.
So compare it to knowing nothing.
You have a huge insight into what's going
on in the world and how valuable the
starts are going to be tomorrow.
Tomorrow hasn't happened yet already
by looking at the prices today,
you have a tremendous idea what
the prices are tomorrow. Okay,
so that's the first thing to notice.
The theories kind of confirmed the
second thing to notice as well,
it doesn't seem perfectly conformed
because this seems like a pretty positive
thing, you know, it seems to be going
up most of the time and as he said,
well we haven't done the discounting yet,
right.
We should've done discounting because
tomorrow is not quite as important to you
as today. So I shouldn't have
just been looking at return.
I should have looked at return,
you know,
per day and so I should have discounted.
Okay.
Just counted each day
by whatever the interest rate is.
Let's say you think it's 4% in a year
divided by 250 since are 250 days a year.
So approximately I should have gotten
250 you know I should have discounted by
that. And so when you do that, the
number gets even much closer to zero.
Okay?
But it doesn't come exactly equal to zero.
And so we're going to see that we need
something else to make up the difference,
but it's such a tiny difference that
needs explaining. So to summarize,
we have this view that uncertainty is
going to change everything that we think
about the world and it will change
a lot of things dramatically,
but it's not going to
change the idea that today,
the price today of things is a pretty
good indicator of what their value is
going to be tomorrow. Okay?
If you replace value tomorrow,
which is uncertain by the
expected value tomorrow,
so you can still learn a tremendous
amount about the world just by looking at
the market. Okay. So that, that,
that's a very important a lesson.
So let's go a little further though.
Suppose that
you thought, well, maybe people, um,
maybe I want to ask a more
complicated question. I want to say,
suppose I only look at stocks
that went up yesterday.
Okay. I only worked look at
stocks that went up yesterday.
Now maybe there's something
about the market that, you know,
momentum will keep carrying
those stocks up tomorrow.
So once the market gets rolling,
you know,
maybe the market's not such
a good forecast. Maybe,
you know, as Schiller says,
they're all these
psychological forces at work.
And once things get rolling and
prices have gone up yesterday,
the price will keep
going up, uh, tomorrow.
So today's price won't be such a good
indicator of tomorrow's price because
tomorrow's price is
probably going to be higher.
So I'm going to repeat now exactly the
same experiment except putting a hundred
doll, except instead of putting
$100 in all the s and p 500,
I only put the hundred dollars into
the stocks that went up yesterday.
Or I might even refine it by,
uh,
selling short the stocks that
went down yesterday. Okay.
So how, what does that do?
Does that change the, uh, numbers?
MMM.
Okay.
So if I blow this up, maybe it is blown
up. You can't do any better than that.
Okay. Does that change the numbers?
Well, no. In fact, it makes it worse.
It's closer to zero now.
Okay. So again, overall,
this time to kind of went up to the
same peak but fell down even further.
So this is thing. So again,
the, the stock prices today,
even if I tried to refine it and get more
clever, I try to fool the market. I say,
okay, the market does
a good job. On average,
today's price is pretty good on average
of predicting tomorrow's prices.
What about today's prices of those
stocks that went up yesterday? You know,
momentum thing. Maybe that's
a, maybe that's not such a
good, maybe on that subset,
the market's not so good. Well, the
market is pretty good on those too. Okay.
So again, you have to, you know, do the
discounting and you have to do the, the,
uh, realize that there are
a huge number of days here.
So this tiny return is really nothing
averaged over all those numbers of days.
Okay. Well let's see if we can
come up with another strategy.
I forgot what other strategy I just
tried out here. Oh, suppose you could,
um,
suppose you could say,
I want to choose only those stocks that
went up 20 days ago or 25 days ago or 14
days ago.
This number here,
these bars here represent for everything
in the essence for the s and p 500.
You try to say, what's the correlation?
You know, that's like the covariance,
but normalize.
So it's between zero and one.
What's the correlation of a
move yesterday and a move today?
Does the fact that the stock went up
yesterday mean that it's going to go up
today?
Or just the fact that the stock went up
three days a ago mean that it's going to
go up today and, uh, you know,
between today and tomorrow.
So if one up two days ago went up
yesterday from yesterday to today,
does that suggest that it's likely
to go up from today to tomorrow?
So with this says, of course if
you only did the experiment once,
you'd always find that it did something.
Okay.
So you have to do many experiments
and then figure out what the,
so this is a statistical thing to
sort of guess what the correlation is.
Estimate the correlation. So, um, it,
and then you have to see
whether it's significant.
So anything in this blue band means
the numbers are insignificant.
So these bars represent
what the correlation is.
So no matter how far back you go,
you basically knowing which
way the stock went. You know,
27 days ago tells you almost nothing
about which way the stock is going to go
today. There's almost no correlation.
If it went up 27 days ago,
it's statistically, you know,
over the last 7,000, 500 days,
slightly more than half the time it
went up again today, but such a few,
such a small fraction of the time. Did
it go up again? Uh, you know, the, the,
the more times up and down that is
statistically insignificant. You know,
if you only do it five times and you're
always going to get three, you know,
it's going to have to
be one way or the other.
So if you do it in an odd number of times,
it can't be exactly even, and you know,
so you just figured out what statistical
significance is. So none of them, hardly,
almost none of them are statistically
significant. So once again,
it's not only the case that today's
prices are good forecasts of tomorrow's
prices, but today's prices, even if you
add some information to it, seem to be,
you know,
even if you tried to refine your set and
look at only buying stocks that 27 days
ago went up,
you're still a prices of those stocks
are still going to be an a reasonably
accurate forecast of tomorrow's prices.
So I did one more experiment,
or Rashid did one more experiment
for me and Casey, here's this.
In a year, he, uh,
he did the same thing on
a portfolio of stocks.
Um, so he looked at a 12
month rolling average.
He looked at the stocks that had done
particularly well in the last 12 months
and he bought those.
And then you looked at the stocks that
doesn't particularly badly on the last 12
months. And he shorted those. And
here's what his returns would have been,
you know, just taking the daily, you know,
thing and just adding it and you'd see
you get almost exactly back to zero.
So this was the original
compelling evidence,
things like this in the
1970s in 1980s led peoples,
uh,
economist to say that the prices of very
many things seem to be very accurate
guides to future prices.
And they called it the rash.
Rationalists loose was
rational expectations.
So the high watermark of this theory
was in 1983 I think the most amusing
example was roll Richard
Role, who taught at, uh,
Ucla, uh, and oranges.
So Richard Role did the
following experiment. He said,
it turns out that for
concentrated orange juice,
97% of the oranges that are used for
concentrated orange juice are grown on
trees that are very close to Orlando,
Florida,
where the weather is pretty much
the same. I mean, it's a small area.
So whatever the weather is,
it's that whether over the whole area.
It's amazing that so many of the
oranges are grown in the same place.
I'm California, I'm talking
about concentrated orange juice.
California is no competition for Florida.
In fact, no competition for Orlando,
Florida when it comes to concentrated
orange juice, not oranges in general.
So he said to himself, um, how
good is the market at predicting,
uh,
you know,
the price of orange juice at predicting
next period's price of orange juice.
And he found you don't just like we did
here. It's quite good. But then he said,
you know, maybe there's other information
that the market doesn't know about.
And so he said,
what about the weather?
So the weather has a tremendous effect
on orange juice prices because if the,
if it's a four hours of
freezing temperatures, kills,
starts to kill the trees,
then you'd get less supply of orange.
Orange is for the concentrated orange
juice, and then the price goes up.
So he said, you know, since 1970 or so,
the u s weather bureau has spent
$250 million building all these,
uh, weather forecasting units that
make daily, in fact, they make 36 hour,
24 hour and 12 hour forecasts of what
the weather's going to be next period.
So he said, really, if the
market is so good, you know,
and the market price today is really
telling an uninformed investor what the
price ought to be tomorrow.
Let me see now by getting a
record of the weather reports,
could I improve on the market price by
putting together today's market price and
the weather report today,
the weather prediction today?
Could I make a better forecast
of the market price tomorrow?
Any found out? No.
Statistically the, uh, weather
plus prices does not improve,
does not improve, um, price forecast.
Okay. So, I mean, how
can you interpret that?
How could that possibly be that knowing
the weather reports dot doesn't help you
predict the price better than the next,
the next day than today's price?
How could that be?
What's the obvious reason for that?
Yup.
Great.
Right?
So the people buying and selling,
they're also looking at the weather
report. And so naturally they've,
they've taken that into account.
But so what it illustrates though is that
all this kind of information that you
might think,
you know,
would go into effecting the value
of the orange juice tomorrow.
The market is already processing that
because the people buying and selling,
they're looking at the weather report
and they're figuring out, you know,
what the right, uh, what
the right price should be.
So that was a pretty stunning conclusion,
but he didn't want to stop there.
So what did he do next?
What if you were, you know how in comp
lit, they always say things backwards.
The reader is detective or the detective
is reader and you know, every, you know,
that's the, anyway, when I
took comp lit, it was always,
that was the gist of every course
was just do everything backwards.
So that's how you knew you were
clever and comp lit. What if,
what would accomplished person have done?
Yes.
He said, okay, let's do, let's use
the price to predict the weather.
So He'd said,
suppose the price,
uh, today turned out to
be higher than the price.
Okay. So the price from yesterday
to today when unexpectedly up.
Okay. So, um, okay.
When unexpectedly up, then he said, okay,
that means these market guys were
surprised today to see the price go up.
You know, there's a weather
forecast back here as well,
and there's a weather forecast
here. And he said, maybe,
um,
you can now say if the price went up,
can you use that to help
forecast the weather? So he said,
suppose that whatever the
forecast is here, you now
say, since the price went up,
we're now going to forecast that the,
the weather guys,
you're the price going up means you're,
you know,
they've learned something here about
the weather probably being bad.
So the question is, did the weatherman
learned the same thing? So he says,
let's test the hypothesis
that when the price went up,
these guys learn more about the weather
than the weather prediction Victor's
dead.
So that in fact the actual weather from
this prediction is likely to go down.
Okay. And that's just what
he found. So, um, you can,
you can't use weather to improve
the price prediction of prices,
but you can use prices to improve the
weather prediction of the weather people.
Okay. So that was us. That was, uh,
that was one of the most stunning,
a confirmation to the rational
expectations hypothesis. So what,
um, could explain that, by the way,
is that just crazy or an accident or is
there some logical explanation for that?
Yeah,
people buying and selling oranges
like no more about the letter
then the government does. So the people
buying and selling oranges, this is,
you know, billions of dollars
of, uh, you know, money trade
changing hands. You know,
the government spent $250 million in this
area, you know, forecasting the weather.
These guys have billions at stake. They
in fact have better forecasting, better,
better weather forecasting technology.
And then the government does and
they're making better forecasts and the
government isn't the weather.
Okay? So if you asked them,
they would know better than the government
what the weather's going to be the
next day and the price reflects
that. Okay. So that's the,
that's the efficient markets hypothesis,
which seduced many in
the economics profession.
And there's still a tremendous amount
of truth to it, at least at the,
at the level.
If you don't know anything and you want
to know something about the future,
look at the prices today,
that's going to tell you a tremendous
amount about the future. Now,
the question is whether it's as
precise as role seems to suggest,
and I'm going to, uh, we're going to see
that it's not going to be, but anyway,
for a while, um, these people,
the rational expectations school,
which is mostly at Chicago,
they had the view that in
Pharma was one of the leaders.
They had the view that this rational
expectations pricing was the best
documented truth and all of the social
sciences. That's what a Pharma said.
So we'll have to come back and see that
that's anyway, not always the case, but,
uh, certainly looks good in these
graphs. Okay. So that's our first, uh,
uh, okay. That's the first idea. Now,
the next idea that we looked at was
what is the most important thing
to be uncertain? Well, you know, there,
there's output that you're uncertain
about what the next most important thing
is, the discount, the
interest rate after all,
that's the most important variable in
the whole economy according to Fisher.
Who's to say the discount is
always exactly the same thing.
So uncertain discounts.
Yeah.
Okay. So now we said, and you've done in
the problem set, if the interest rate,
you know,
is 100% and might go up to 200%,
say or might go down to 50%,
and now you, uh, now you want to
ask, what's the value of a dollar?
Here it's a little subtler. You, um, Eh,
you don't because here the
expectation was all that mattered.
The expectation of the payoffs.
If I change this to 106
and I changed this to 96,
I haven't changed.
I haven't changed the expectation.
So the price is going to stay the same.
So the variants has nothing to do
with what the prices, but that's not,
but things can get subtler.
Let's suppose that what's changing is the
interest rate. The discount rate. Okay.
Now the variance is going to have a big
effect on what the value of things are.
So if we think this is happening with 50,
50 probability, the guy, if he, so he,
so what do I mean by this model today?
You know that the value of something
tomorrow is going to be a half of what it
pays tomorrow up plus a half what it
pays tomorrow down discounted by 100%
tomorrow.
You're not sure whether you're going to
be discounting at 200% or discounting
and 50% so then the value today is going
to be one over one plus 100% times,
okay?
Um,
a half times one over one plus 200% of
one plus a half times one over one plus a
50% times one,
okay?
Because over here you know that this
dollar is only going to be worth the third
to you. Over here, you know this
dollar is going to be worth two thirds.
So that's the two thirds here and the
one third here and there's a 50 50 chance
of each of these and you're going to
discount it by one over a hundred percent
so that's what the value is to you today.
Okay.
So now you did a problem set where you
had to do a bunch of these things. Okay.
And we're going to call that d have to
cause that's what you would pay today to
get a dollar for sure at time to in the
future.
And Dee have one,
he's going to be just one over
one plus a hundred percent okay.
Which is a half.
Okay.
Which is what you would pay today to
get a dollar for sure at time one.
And I could compute the of three
and any other d that I wanted to.
Okay, so why, so we're going to see
that interest rate uncertainties,
the most important
uncertainty in the economy,
the value of everything is
going to change. You know,
if the interest rates go up,
all the bonds are going
to go down in value.
All the mortgages are going to change in
value. Although sometimes they don't go,
they go in surprising directions,
but everything's going to change in value.
When the interest rate moves,
that's gonna subject everybody
to tremendous amounts of risk.
And we have to figure out how are they
going to cope with all that risk. Well,
before we answer that question, we want
to answer the, the simpler question.
How are they going to value things?
And here we just have the
same tree that we had before.
So that's what we did last class. And I
just wanted to, to finish that thought,
which I didn't get a chance to do. So
for, for, for period three, you know,
if we could've done a three period thing
and assumed that this went up to 400%
and uh, you know, would
have gone to 100%, um,
or down to 25%.
Okay,
then still paid one, one, one. Okay.
So that's pay off for a dollar for sure.
But now we've got still more uncertainty
in the interest rates. So what's the,
you know,
you figured out in the problem set what
the value of that is going to be and you
got d three okay,
so I could have done this for d four
and any other tea that I wanted to.
And in fact that's also what you
did in the, in the problem set.
You did it for all the
way up to [inaudible].
Okay.
So I want now to just say one thing about
the environment before we're going to
come back and analyze this over and over
again to see the risk the whole economy
is exposed to and how people cope with
that risk of interest rates changing.
But I want to make one observation.
These numbers,
d one d two d three d four there they
reflect people's attitudes towards the
future. What would you pay today
to get a dollar at time one?
What would you pay today
to get a dollar a time too.
What would you pay today to
get a dollar at a time? Three.
So what does the shape of that function?
Well in the case of certainty
with a constant discount rate,
that function would have to
decline exponentially. Okay,
so it'd be an exponential decline.
Yeah.
Why?
Because it would be,
this would be equal to one over one plus
r and this would be equal to one over
one plus r squared and this would be equal
to one over one plus r to the fourth,
et Cetera.
So after a hundred years or 500 years,
you wouldn't care as long as our is,
you know,
like 0.03 or something
percent quenelle three Rs,
3% as long as there's a number,
like 2% or 3% after 500 years,
you just don't care at all about
what's going to happen. The, you know,
if the whole economy and the society is
discounting the future and trading it
off like this,
you don't care at all about the future.
So environmental improvements today with
Joan have an effect for 200 years would
be regarded as stupid
ideas and environment.
Mentalist have been trying desperately
to make an argument that 200 years from
now really matters. And so of course
they argue about the interest rate,
but really all they're doing is they're
arguing that the interest rate, you know,
instead of being 3% should be 1% or
something like that there, you know, and,
and that's not really
helping because even 1%,
if you keep doing that for 500 years,
you're going to get a pretty
trivial number by the end. So, um,
so let me ask you the following question.
Suppose you could have $15 today
or so. This is an experiment. Failure Ran.
He's a behavioral economist.
So next month,
okay.
Hey,
one year and 10 years,
how much money would you want next month
instead of the $15 today to someone
give a number. Just shout out a
number. What seems equivalent to you?
20 and it happens to be
exactly what the average,
I don't know if you
read my that's exactly.
Do you know of a sailor experiment
or it's precisely the average.
Thaler did a class like this, averaged
all the numbers. He got 20. Amazingly.
What about for one year?
What would you say?
50 to 100. Okay. And what about 10 years?
okay,
so I'll tell you the Fayler numbers.
I stupidly forgot them all when it Turkey.
Um,
okay,
so the numbers of Thaler.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let's just go with those numbers.
But what do you think about
those numbers? Okay, so Thaler,
God.
Okay,
so it's amazing.
Fayler got 2050 and a
hundred were sailors numbers.
So very close to what you're telling me.
50 and a hundred so what's
the matter with those numbers?
Let's go with failers. They weren't
that different from yours. Okay. What,
what's the problem with failers numbers?
What?
Yeah,
rapidly, rapidly. This is just one month.
You have to have a huge discount to care,
but you know,
this is your discounting by
33% or something a month.
So tremendous discount to go from
here to here. If he did that 12 times,
you would have gotten a tight.
So if you look at the monthly
discount rate from here to here,
you know you get like 33% from
here to here. It's to the 12 power.
So you're just counting, but
you know, 5% from here to here.
You've got to the hundred 20th power.
So what number to the hundred 20th
gives you, you know, six and two thirds,
not a very big number. In fact, you know,
the reciprocal of that number
is the discount is 0.75 is,
is he a 0.75 to the one?
Okay,
so this is 0.75 obviously,
and then 15 over 50 to the one 10th.
Okay.
One 12 is point. Um, you know,
it was 0.9 and then 15 over
100 to the one 20th this 0.98.
Okay. So you're discounting
by 33%, you know,
something like that by 10% and then by 2%.
So your discount rate is falling rapidly.
Oh,
you do experiments with, with uh,
animals. You get the same conclusion.
You asked the animals,
you know, how, you know,
you can make an animal work and then
they'll have to wait a certain time to get
the food. Or if they, you
know, uh, work harder,
they can get more food, but they have
to wait a certain amount of, you know,
longer amount of time.
So you try and do the experiment.
I'm not sure these actually a, you
know, are believable. But anyway,
they do these experiments and they, they
figure out how much the animal is trait.
You know, these are birds and mice and
all kinds of things trading off waiting,
um, you know, for getting a bigger
reward and they get the similar,
similar kinds of numbers to what
Taylor got by talking to a psychologic,
you know, psychological experiments
with, with real people. Well,
how can you explain it in the
world of constant discounting?
You couldn't possibly explain it.
Now of course you could explain it by
saying everybody's discount rate is going
to get smaller and smaller over time.
Okay.
But that their annual discount rate is
getting smaller and smaller over time.
But that's totally unbelievable. You know,
and it's just, you know, why should you,
you know, that a year from now if you
were asked the same kinds of questions,
you'd give the same kind of answers.
So your discount between today and next
month is going to be the same next year
as it is now.
Okay.
So it's not the case that the one month
this count and you don't happens to be
high now because you're,
you know,
you're in college and then the
day you got out of college,
you're going to be more mature.
And so you're going to have a smaller
discount rate. When you get to my age,
you're going to be even more mature
and have a smaller discount rate.
That doesn't happen. The discount rate
doesn't go down like that. In fact,
if anything, I don't, if
you're rational out to go up,
I'm closer to death than you are and
you're off. I don't get this stuff now.
Who knows when I'll ever get it.
So the discount rate should be going up,
not going down. And yet it
seems like there's so much
evidence that it goes down.
So this is a big puzzle,
uh, in, in, in economics.
So I just offer, again, I got to make
it a habit now of offering theories.
I'm not saying this is the right theory,
I'm just simply pointing out that if you
had this, uh, random discount, you know,
put uncertainty into the discount,
put uncertainty into the interest rates,
you know, uncertain in the interest
rates is the heart of finance.
Every single person, every single
series finance person, um, thinks about,
ran, you know, the uh, um, what do
you call it? Uncertain, you know,
variability in interest rates.
And so I take the simplest
possible process when the
interest rates can go up or
down by the same percentage.
So for example, by four start,
you could start at 4% and then the,
the uh,
you know, the variation or the
standard deviation, it could be 16%.
Okay.
Which means that 4% basically goes to
4% times 1.16 or to 4% times divided by
1.16.
That process
actually either the one times e to the
0.16 or a times e to the minus 0.16,
which is very close to times 1.16.
That geometric random walk is
the basic model of finance.
And what you found in your homework is
you're supposed to find that as you go
out further and further,
the effect of discount rate does go down.
And what I forgot to say,
the punchline is, if you've,
if failers numbers here,
confirm what all the
behavioral economists suggests,
which is that there's hyperbolic
discounting, hyperbolic discounting.
So what they do,
what they confirm in these
experiments is that if this is DFT,
this should go down like a
tea to some power, you know,
t to the, you know, t to the, um,
minus some power to you,
the minus two or t to the minus a half or
something like that. They get, you know,
some, you know, they don't
pin down with this numbers,
but t to the minus say so it
goes down much slower than,
than she was I just much slower than
the exponent, which is, you know,
some exponent like 0.9 to the t that
goes down much faster than that does.
This is a polynomial and,
t this is an exponential and t,
so it's going down much faster.
So this is a classic failers numbers
are a classic polynomial. In fact,
with exponent, a half
failers numbers fit tea, uh,
to minus a half if you do
the right starting point.
So what did I show?
I show that any geometric random walk,
no matter where you start, no matter what
our zero has, no matter what you start,
no matter what standard
deviation you'll go.
If you figure out the sequence of numbers,
d one d two d three d
four not up to 30 years,
which is where everybody else
stopped because bonds into 30 years,
but you do it for a hundred or 200 or
500 d of t is always eventually going to
be equal to some constant
times 10 to the minus a half.
Exactly.
Consistent with failers numbers.
So I don't know if that's the
explanation to hyperbolic discounting,
but I thought it was pretty interesting
and anyone could have done it if they
just didn't stop at 30 years.
Just kept going.
And then there's some mathematics too.
You know, you can compute examples,
but there's some mathematics to
prove that asks them topically.
That's the right formula.
Okay. So in fact,
in this paper I wrote this with a
coauthor dome farmer whose daughter is a
sophomore here and his son just
graduated by the way, he's in Santa Fe.
And so if you look at the picture here,
you can see that this exponent,
these are the d of t's when
you exponentially discount,
I've got it on a logarithmic scale.
So if you exponentially discount things,
go the ds drop off really fast,
that's the dotted line really fast.
But if you do this random thing,
you get the thing that goes much slower
and it goes with a slope of minus a half.
So let's just, since I plotted things on
log scale, that's just what this means.
Taking the log of this, you get a
straight line with slope minus a half.
And that's just what we
found. And we, you know,
manage to prove that that always has to
happen. Okay? So if you look, you know,
500 years in the future,
you start with 4% and you
assume a constant discount
rate after 500 years in the
exponential, nobody could possibly care
about 500 years from now. But you know,
500 years from now was 1% as
important as now if you, um,
discount at this, you
know, if you start out,
if everyone knows the interest rates
4% now and it's going to go up or down,
keep going forever.
So it's a quite shocking.
Okay, so that's the, that's it.
So we're gonna come back over and over
again to this and this is the yield curve
that you would get the
zero yield per like,
and the problem set goes up and then
starts coming back there. All right.
Does anyone want to say anything about
discounting or how to compute this stuff?
Do you know how I did this?
Yes.
Yeah. Um, okay. So the, the immune,
the intuition of why that ha you
computed it new. Found it happen. Okay.
What's the intuition?
The intuition is that,
so why should this thing,
okay,
go up and then go down just like you
competed in the problem that the reason is
because if the, if the, uh,
interest rate is moving in
a geometric random walk.
So it's doubling or getting multiplied
by a half, the geometric average is,
it stays where it was before.
But that means since the
arithmetic average is always
bigger than the geometric
average,
the arithmetic average of 200% and
50% is actually bigger than a 100%.
So at the beginning you're sort of,
you're going to be doing this geometric,
this arithmetic average and things are
going to be getting bigger for a while,
but when you go out farther and
farther, why doesn't that matter? Okay,
so what is the intuition?
Yeah,
and,
and by the way,
this is a common thing and finance with
someone named Weitzman who was at Yale,
announce at Harvard, um, did, uh,
suggest this idea in economics.
He said, for the environment,
you should always use the lowest
possible interest rate. And why is that?
Let's do an example.
Suppose the interest rate was
going to go to 100% one over.
So you're going to multiply by one over
two and then keep multiplying by one
over two forever.
Interest rates stayed the same.
Or let's say you were going to mop,
the interest rate was going to be a less
discounting to over three and was going
to stay there forever.
Okay.
And you get one here or one here.
So I'm doing a very simple case where 50%
of the time it stays at a 100% forever
and 50% of the time it goes to 50% this
is 100% and this is 50% Brian is the
interest rate stays at 100% forever
or 50% forever. So you discount,
you multiply by two thirds forever or,
or by a half forever.
So this could happen with probability
a half and this could happen with
probability a half if you average
this multiplied all the haves and this
multiplied by all the thirds,
by the all the two thirds,
the half is irrelevant because this is
such a tiny number compared to this one,
right?
Because every time you're multiplying by
such a small number up here compared to
this, this thing just is negligible
compared to this. So really the, the, the,
the total here is entirely given
by what happened down here. Okay?
So it's two thirds to the nth power times
one plus a totally negligible thing.
Okay?
So you're going to have half of this
value is going to be the value here.
So the high interest rate, the hundred
percent interest rate didn't matter.
It's only the low interest rates
that matter. So why is that?
Because of the random walk and when you
follow a random walk it goes like that.
So if you end up with a really
low interest rate at the end,
so here we start with 4% by the end,
you know,
cause it's a random walk,
you don't know where the final
interest rate's going to be.
It's going to be some normally
distributed thing like that.
You know what the final
interest rate's going to be.
But the low interest
rates here at the end,
here's where the interest rate was the
same as where you started back to 4% so
I'm not saying that people
typically go down here.
That would be a ridiculous assumption.
I'm saying on average they're at
the same level they were today,
but the past where the interest rate
ends up high probably were high the whole
way along. So they kept getting discounted
so they don't make any difference.
The pads with the interest rate went was
low path was probably low the whole way
along. And that's why those are
much more relevant past the knees.
So when you take your average to get it,
it's going to be in this particular
example though, as if it was two thirds,
50% discounting forever. But of course
we're only averaging over these low pass.
So I have to put a half in front of it.
That's why it's not 10 to the minus half.
It's an ae times t to the minus half.
Okay.
So that's the, okay, so
that's what vague intuition,
but it maybe helps a little bit
figuring out why that happens. Okay.
So I don't know, this may have some
significance for the environment.
So I personally think that we should
do something about the environment,
even if it's only gonna be 500 years away,
I don't think we should just discount it
to zero because the interest rates are
4% and 4% of the 500th
power is some tiny number
that is one over 1.04 to some
500th power is a tiny number. Okay,
so I'm going to march on
now there are no questions.
What's the next most important kind of
uncertainty that you see in the market?
All the time.
Okay.
It's the chance of default.
Now we're going to see very shortly that
default and the possibility of default
changes a lot of things.
But you could still be
irrational expectations guy
and believe that the fault is
just, it's no big deal.
It's just that the payoff,
which over here was 104 and 98 the
fall just makes the payoff lower.
So what's the typical thing
that the faults, it's a bond.
So
they would go thing
that default is a bond.
So suppose I had,
suppose I had a one
year bond from Argentina
that could pay a hundred
or it could pay zero is Argentine bond.
So you'll have to forgive me if you're
from Argentina and then we have the
American bond that can pay a
hundred or I can pay a hundred
okay,
so,
well I might the RJ. Okay, so what do
you see if you look at American bonds,
so these both promise a
hundred the American bond,
if you look at the market today,
is going to sell for a higher price
in the Argentine bond. Why is that?
Because people assume that the American
bond is not going to default. Okay?
So even if you put a zero here,
they assume that the probability for
the American bond is one here and the
probability, the Argentine bond, you know,
is some number 0.8 or 0.2 or something.
Question is what's the
number that they put there?
But so there's uncertainty
about defaulting and if
defaulting means paying zero,
we're going to think a second
about what it really means.
If it means paying zero,
that's no big deal.
We just in calculating the expected payoff
we have to take into account and not
the usual dividends and all that stuff,
plus a hundred.
We also have to take into account
the possibility things to fall. Okay.
So let's, let's, uh,
look at some of those curves.
Hmm.
Oh No.
Did I forget the curves?
All right, hang on.
So I got another one on mine.
MMM.
Oh dear. I got another one of my, uh,
you think I'm on the Internet
in here by the way? No.
Oh, I didn't realize this would
happen when I lost the Internet.
I had opened the file, but it doesn't, uh,
okay.
Yes. Okay. It's only, take a second.
Yeah.
All wireless
connection successful.
Okay. So I can close this
and now I,
all right, sorry. It only take one more
second. I beg your pardon for this.
I had it,
it disappeared when I walked over here.
Okay. So what, so it's going to take a
second for me to get on the Internet.
So what could we do here?
We could figure out what the
price of the Argentine bond was.
So suppose the price of the Argentine
bond is 80 and the price of the American
bond is 95 is a 95
okay.
Okay.
What do you think,
what do you think are w w w what does
the market think the chance of Argentina
defaulting is?
How would you figure that out?
So it's right d here
and one minus the here.
So you don't know anything about
Argentina. You know, it's a great country.
They have, you know, wonderful
everything, music, beautiful people,
everything, you know. Okay.
But their bonds happened to sell for
a lower price than American bonds do.
So assuming the American
bonds can't the fault,
because we're just going to print the
money and Argentina might default because
maybe they've tied their
payments to the dollars,
so they can't just print the money.
What do you think d is?
How can you figure out what the is?
Oh, that's bad. Oh dear.
Well,
so you know, in my Yale Mail, this
all goes to junk. But in the on there,
this is really bad.
You'll have to cut that out.
Oh No. Uh, oh no.
You can't infer anything from that.
Oh,
okay.
So here is the,
mmm,
let's do JP Morgan.
Oh, what a disaster. Um, okay, so this,
so, okay, so let's, where
did I get that graph?
Let's just do this problem for the art.
So this is j p Morgan and this
is the chance of defaulting.
So you see that or know this JP Morgan,
what are the chances that after one year
JP Morgan's going to go out of business?
The market thinks it's surprisingly high.
A percent and a half.
I should have asked you what
you thought after 10 years.
They think that JP Morgan,
you know the, the, the leader,
the Great Investment Bank,
which is now a real
regular bank and you know,
the most successful that they think
10% the market thinks it will be out of
business within 10 years.
Okay. So how did we,
how to get that number? Well, let's,
you know, and we can do another one.
We can do Citibank.
Citibank is a totally lousy American Bang.
That ought to have gone
out of business already,
but it's being propped
up by the government. So,
of course people think the government's
going to keep it propped up.
So over a year it's actually got a
smaller probability or about the same
probability as JP Morgan because everybody
knows the government's going to keep
propping it up.
But then you know,
eventually maybe the government's gonna
stop worrying about Gee, about Citibank.
And so after 10 years,
Citibank, the biggest,
what used to be the biggest bank in the
world has got a 25% chance of going out
of business. 25% that won't
even say 20 years. Yeah,
25% it won't even be here. Okay. So
how did I know what those numbers were?
How did the Ellington
trader figure that out?
Every morning they figure out the interest
rates and they figure out the implied
default probabilities. So what is
the implied default probability,
this Argentine bond,
how would you figure that out?
Well, according to our theory, what
is the price of the origin team bond
80 what should I write that equal to
what?
Okay,
one minus d times what?
Okay.
Okay. Well that's very good. So,
let me just see how she, lets,
so where are you? Okay,
excellent. But you went too fast.
You've got the right answer,
but it was just very fast. Okay?
So it's one that the payoff
of the Argentine behind is
one mine in Steve Times a
hundred plus d times zero. Okay?
So that's the expected payoff.
That's what you expect to happen here.
But she went,
so she not only did that, but she
went one step further and she said,
how would you, um, how would you,
uh, you have to discount it. So how does
she know how much to discount it? Well,
you could buy an American bond
just as well as an Argentine bond.
So basically we know that the
discount, right? The world discount,
everybody has the Argentines
can buy the American bonds.
And so $100 for sure is worth 95.
So here's the excel.
According to our hypothesis,
you take the expected payoff and
then multiplied by the discount,
95 over a hundred.
So that's equal justice.
She said to one minus D turns 95.
That's what she said as
she was exactly right.
So therefore you can figure out
that one minus D is 80 over 95.
Okay.
And so d is
one minus 80, over 95.
Okay. Which is, you know,
something like 15%,
a little bit more, maybe it's
16%, something like that.
So it looks like there's a chance
of 16% that Argentina is to default.
Yeah.
So that's how they figured out.
Um,
that's how they figured out what
all these default probabilities are.
Any questions about that?
Let's see if we could do a
two period version. Okay. So
they've done one one year.
Now I'm not going to show
you what Argentina is.
Last year I got to show everybody
what Argentina was. Unfortunately,
my hedge funds,
emerging market
trade or one out of business last year
on the crisis lost a lot of money.
So we closed it down. So I
can't show you what, uh, are.
Um, so I don't have, it's too complicated
and why I didn't bother to get all the,
all the, uh, you know, countries,
uh, prices on the default curves.
You don't bother to compute them anymore
because we're not training them all
right now. But we still are trading
all these potential corporate bonds.
All right?
Suppose it was two years
old. We had a two year
thing. So this is the u s
okay.
Okay.
Now I'm going to do a simplified version
first and then we're going to have to
complicated.
Um,
okay.
Okay.
So I guess I'm assuming that we're doing
okay.
Okay. So let's do the case
where we're doing zeroes. Okay.
So it's a here's America
and hearings Argentina,
and we're just going to be trading zeros.
Okay?
So it's going to get a little
more complicated with, um,
when their dividends,
but not so much cause it's complicated.
So there's a two year.
Okay? So those curves should be
parallels. So here's Argentina.
Now let's say that the American,
so here we've got the one
year bond pays off in the um,
um, yellow. So one one here,
and let's assume it doesn't really matter,
but let's assume that that price is 0.9
and then the zero, the two
years here in America, which
pays off one, one, one here.
It's all, just write that
in pink one, one, one.
Okay.
Hey, is worth 70. What did I do? 72.
Okay, now let's do the same thing in
Argentina. Let's say the one year bond,
which off one here and zero
there, okay, this is the fault.
So it's probability d,
Let's say the probability of
DIYs always the same, okay? Um,
the one year Argentine bond,
let's say is worth 0.7 is worth 0.54
and the two year is two one six. Let's
say. So now, what is the two year?
So we have to look at these paths.
What is the two year Argentine bond going
to be worth? It will be worth one here,
zero here. But now if the one
year Argentine bond defaults,
it's the same country.
So they've gone out of business and
aren't going to pay their one year.
They're not going to pay
their two year either.
So it's going to be zero here in here.
So let's assume that's the payoff. Okay?
So here we know that the one
year American bond is 90 cents.
The one year zero,
the two year American zero 72
cents and the one year Argentine,
uh, zero is 50. What did I say?
54 and the two years is 21.6 cents.
Okay, so how are we going to figure
out what these uh, and, and, and why?
Assume the same default probability.
I think I'd make it more interesting
and assume d one and d two after all.
And those curves that
changes d one and D two.
Okay, so [inaudible] is
actually quite irrelevant there.
So what? Um, okay, so this doesn't
matter. So we've just got D two.
Okay. So solving for d one is going
to give me, all right, so what do I,
what do I do now?
How would I solve this?
What do you think I should do?
How do I get the one in d two?
Which would I saw four first.
The
one,
this is probably one here,
one here or it doesn't matter.
You go call them on ones.
So in fact,
let's put in the same tree and
call this one minus day one.
And this is one minus d two.
This is Argentina defaulting
or not defaulting and
America still going have the
u s bond is still going to pay what it's
promised, no matter whether Argentina.
So this is the Argentina tree
and this is the Americans,
the same tree with the American payoffs
over on the right on the bottom tree,
but it's the same tree on top of that one.
So how would I fit?
Which would I get first?
Do you want her d two
okay,
the one.
Okay,
so I know that one minus Dijuan times one.
that's there plus d one times zero.
That's the expected payoff of
the one year. Argentine bond
times what
equals a 0.54
is that, is that how I should solve
for Dijuan or am I missing something?
Point nine you have to
discount it by 0.9 okay,
so then we could solve very easily,
we would get one minus d one
one minus Dijuan equals
0.54 over 0.9 right,
because this is just zero.
So I just wrote one minus is one over
here and I divided the 0.9 there.
That happens to work out very nicely
to 60% so we know that the chance of
default is 40% in the first year.
Okay. Now what's the chance
of default in the second year,
assuming you haven't defaulted
already in the first year,
if you defaulted in the first year,
you've wiped out everything anyway. Uh,
including the two year zero. So what,
what should I write now to get beat too?
Well, with probability, um,
the only way to get paid is to go up here.
So I'd have to go one minus d one
times one minus d two
times one.
That's the only way to get any money.
The rest isn't paying me anything.
Times what?
All right, ms what? I'm sorry. Times what?
Didn't hear it. Point seven
two yes. I don't know.
I sounded like one 17 0.72 that didn't
make any sense. One 17th all right,
so 0.72 exactly is going to equal 0.216.
Okay.
So now all I have to do is I have to
realize that a one minus d two a equals
0.216 over 0.72 m w times
one over one minus d one.
Okay? So that happens to be, um,
0.3 is it happens to be,
okay
0.3 I guess 0.3 times one over one minus
d one we just got that was 0.6 over 0.6
which equals um,
0.51
minus d one we saw was 0.6.
I've got a 0.6 down here and this over,
this is 0.3 so it's 0.3
or 1.6 which is just 0.5.
So we now know that this
probability is 0.55 d 2.5 so,
so 50% I could,
right.
Okay. So actually it's quite interesting.
We know that the probability,
I wonder whether this was cumulative
default must be cumulative default.
So we know that um, things are
getting worse. In Argentina.
The first year,
there's a 40% chance of default.
But even if you get through
the first year, the next year,
there's going to be a 50%
chance of default. Okay.
So things are getting worse and worse and
worse in Argentina. Uh, in this example,
I'm not saying in real life in this
example, okay. But by doing this, uh, for,
for any bond of any
corporation or any country,
you can learn a lot about what the,
what the market thinks about that country.
So the market doesn't think very much of,
of a,
Citibank could think Citibank in
10 years, could have, you know,
25% chance of going out of business.
And for JP Morgan,
it things a lot better of JP Morgan,
but surprisingly not as much
better as you would've expected.
They could go out of business
with 10% probability.
There's very little chance they're going
to go out of business in the next year
or two. Mainly because the government is,
they're protecting them all. Okay. But in,
in 10 years, you know, it, it
could be very different. All right?
And so that's a shocking to most people.
I think shockingly high probability
to those things going out of business.
You wouldn't know yourself
what those things were,
except if you looked at the market.
Now,
I actually could have
computed the prices this way,
which is way the way we used
to compute them at Ellington.
But there's a more direct
way of computing them.
There's a something called a credit
default swap credit default swap.
Okay.
And I credit default slopped swap pays
$1 in case a bond defaults on defaults
within some time period.
Okay.
Okay. It actually pays $1 for
every dollar of principle.
MMM.
$1 in case a bond defaults
within some time period.
More Pr. So I assume here that
when you default you get zero.
So you don't always get zero.
Sometimes the guy is willing to work out
something and pay you part of what he
owed you. Okay. Because after all,
Argentine, if they default, you know,
and the u s is angry about it can put
a lot of pressure on Argentina and
refusing to trade with it,
doing all sorts of other things.
Not that much pressure, but some
pressure and, and so maybe Argentina,
if it can't pay,
it will agreed to pay less and say,
let's forget about the whole thing.
You understand why we can't pay,
we're just bad things happen. It
wasn't our fault. It was unlucky.
So don't hold to it. Take a little bit
less and let us get on with our lives.
Okay.
So instead of putting Zeros down here,
maybe you would put a recovery down there.
So we'll have to come back to that.
So in case if there's a recovery,
the credit default swap pays only the
gap between what it was promised and what
it actually pay.
So it pays a $1,
okay.
Pays, you know, 100% of the loss.
Okay? Uh, for any bond that the faults,
so pays a hundred percent
of loss
in case a bond defaults
within some time period, okay?
Now that's,
if you buy one credit default swap,
you could buy 50 credit
default swaps on the same bond.
So then you'd get 50 times the loss.
So we're going to come back.
This is going to be one of the causes
of the crisis that these credit default
swaps got written that were so big.
So you wouldn't have to actually do
the computation I just showed you.
You could just look at what the
price of the credit default swap is.
Cause here if the payoff is zero,
that means the credit default swaps
going to pay the whole hundred so it's
priced at 16 that's telling you that
everybody thinks it wouldn't be six.
So what would the price of the credit
default swap be over here by the way,
wouldn't be 16 as I just
said that was wrong.
What would the credit default
swap price be over here?
right.
So the credit default swap over here
would have a price equal to point of 16
right? At 16 at 16 the
default rate is, is 0.16.
Okay, so it's going to pay a hundred
here. That's how much it default advice.
So it's going to be 6.16 times
a hundred that's what it pays.
Um, so pays a hundred with probability
0.16, but then it's discounted.
So it's times 95 over a hundred.
Okay.
That's what the price of
the credit default swap is.
So if you knew what the value,
what if you knew the price
of the credit default swap,
you could equally get the default.
This is d over here is just a dean.
So knowing d of course that tells
you the credit default swap.
Knowing the price of
the credit default swap,
you could get d so you could
deduce d in two different ways,
either from the uh,
American bond price or from
the a credit default swap.
In either case you have to know the
American bond price in order to figure out
what the discount rate is. So the
credit default swap is sort of overkill.
It's another way,
you know,
uses all the information plus more to
get the same answer more quickly. Okay.
Now what would the credit default swap
be worth over here? A little subtler.
What's the credit default swap worth here?
So credit default swap fault
swap on Argentine two year bond
equals what?
What would it be worth?
How much would you pay for the
credit default swap in this case?
Well,
Eh,
to your bond over two year horizon.
Okay. So it's only a tiny bit slept
with them before, you know, the,
the two year bond could default
in any one of two cases. Okay.
So it could default here
or it could default here.
So you're going to get,
um, the American 0.9,
right? That's the discount. I don't
know if you can see it over there.
So let's write it over here.
You could get the American
over here. What's the, what's,
what's the value of going down
here? It's one minus t one. Okay.
Discounted by 0.9 times a hundred
times one. I guess the payoff is one
here in this case. Times one. Okay.
Or You could get,
you could get paid over here.
So either the, when the one year
defaults, the two years defaulting to,
so you can get your paid here or you could
wait and get paid over here. So plus,
um, here it's, no,
this was wrong. It's 0.9
Times d one times one. Right?
Because they get paid over here,
you have to default or you
can get paid over here,
which means that you didn't
default the first period,
but then you did the fault the
second period you get paid one.
But we've got to discount that.
How much do we have to discount that by
what we have to do the payments coming
in the second period,
which in America is discounted at the
rate and 0.72 so that some is going to
give you the value of
the credit default swaps.
So d one we know is 0.4 and this is 0.6
so it's going to be 0.36 plus 0.438 so
it's equal to 0.36 plus point fourth uh,
three two
oh 0.432 times d two
which is 50% so 0.216.
Okay,
so that equals 0.576.
Okay.
So that's how much you would pay for
the credit default swap over a two year
horizon on a two year Argentine
bond you've paid today.
Point five seven six I think I
managed to compute that correctly.
Um,
all right,
so I want to end this discussion
of the fault with one,
one observation,
one forum,
which is that you can get all
these numbers incredibly fast.
How can you get these numbers
incredibly fast? What's a trick? Okay.
If recovery is zero, so I'm only
going to talk two more minutes here.
I realize I've come to the end of time.
If recovery is zero,
okay.
If recovery is zero, the chance of
deaf and, and the default, you know,
if you default the first period,
you default on all the bonds.
If you default the second period,
Then the trick that she, the, the,
that young lady who asked the first
question pointed out right away is that,
I don't know where I wrote it, is
that the chance of default, okay.
From the very first equation is going
to be very simple to compute because
you've got the, the uh, oh,
I don't lost your equation anyhow.
Um, but okay. Because from the first,
from the first equation where we
had the chance of default here,
we just got one minus D is this 80?
MMM.
Okay.
How did we get this?
We had the price of the Argentine
bond is 80 compared to the, okay,
so,
and the American bond prices 95 so we
just took 80 over 95 that ratio was the
chance of not defaulting
and the first year, okay,
so she did this incredibly quickly. This
was a faster way of doing it. The, the,
the Argentine bond is worth
80 95th so the American bond,
they're only paying in one state.
That means the chance of Argentina Pang
divided by the chance of America paying.
That's the only state where you're getting
me money must be 80 over 95 so that's
a very fast way of figuring
out what one minus D is.
And for the two period thing,
it's equally fast. Okay,
so you just do one minus d two
all right, well, I'm going
to have to start with this
next, next time. But anyway,
one minus t two is equally fast.
So if you look at it the right way,
you can compute all these
defaults extremely quickly.